what the hell are we doing here us
humans on this earth
how do you think of humans how special
are humans
how did human civilization
originate on this earth
and what is this human project that
we're all taking on
you mentioned uh fire and water and
apparently bleeding you to death is not
a good idea i thought always thought you
can get the demons out in that way but
um that was a recent
invention so what what's this thing
we're doing here
i think what distinguishes uh human
beings from all the other creatures on
the earth is
is
our ability to engineer
we're engineers
right to solve problems or just
build incredible cool things
engineering
harnessing energy and technique to make
the world a better place than you found
it
right from the point that we actually
started to play with fire
right that was a big leap forward
uh harnessing the power of of kinetic
energy and missiles another another step
forward
every city built on water why water well
water's uh bringing energy right if you
actually
if you actually put a turbine you know
on a river or you uh
or you capture a change in elevation of
water you've literally harnessed
gravitational energy but you know water
is also bringing you food it's also
giving you you know
a cheap form of getting rid of your
waste it's also giving you free
transportation
you want to move one ton blocks around
you want to move them in water so
i think i mean the the human story is
really the story of engineering a better
world
um and
and uh the rise in the human condition
is determined by those uh groups of
people those civilizations that were
best at harnessing energy
right if you if you look
you know the greek civilization they
built it around around ports and
seaports and and water and created a
trading network
the romans were really good at
harnessing all sorts of of engineering i
mean the aqueducts are a great example
if you go to any big city
you travel through cities in the med you
find that you know the caring capacity
of the city or the island is 5 000
people without running water and then if
you can find a way to bring water to it
increases by a factor of 10
and so
human flourishing is really only
possible through that channeling of
energy
right that eventually takes the
the form of uh
air power right i mean
that ship
i mean look at the intricacy of those
sails
right i mean it's
just the model is intricate now think
about all of the experimentation that
took place to figure out how many sales
to put on that ship and how to rig them
and how to repair them and
how to operate them
there's thousands of lies spent thinking
through all the tiny little details um
all to increase the efficiency of this
the effectiveness the efficiency of this
ship
as it sails through water
and we should also note there's a bunch
of cannons on the side so obviously
another form of engineering right
energy harnessing with
explosives to achieve what end that's
another discussion exactly
you